Another possible way we might deal with that is to use hassattr. This is a test
of whether an object has a particular attribute. Hassattr is a built in operator
and has attribute a value of true of the object has an attribute with the given
name. As an example, if fussy is a DiscerningBear instance, if we ask if fussy
has an attribute, knockdowntree, we'll get true. But if we ask if it has a
climb_tree attribute, we'll get false. That's because it's a grizzly bear, which
doesn't have a climb_tree. Using has attribute, we could define bear chase like
this. Almost identical to what we did before with this instance. Except for now,
we're using hassattr instead of this instance. And instead of checking if it's a
black bear or a grizzly bear, we're checking whether it has a climb_tree or a
knockdowntree attribute.